this great big story was made possible
by png
love over bias
bayer dresden was one of the most
important figures in the
african-american struggle for civil
rights and freedom he organized the 1963
march on washington he helped dr king
translate the philosophy of non-violence
into direct action
but a lot of people don't know his name
largely because he was a gay man
[Music]
my name is walter nagle and buyer
dresden was the love of my life
i met byron on a corner
at 42nd street in 7th avenue times
square in 1977. i was 27 years old and
he was 65.
there was this tall handsome very
attractive
man standing next to me and we looked at
each other and i was pretty much toast
wired was open about his being gay
really from his teenage years he just
believed in being his authentic self and
speaking his own truth
i had always said that dr king didn't
really have a personal problem with him
being gay dr king really needed byron at
different times because byron was a
person of great creativity great
intellect and he was doing things for
the movement that really nobody else
could do
after the march on washington he became
a much more visible figure
he was really out there in the thick of
the movement you're interested in making
it possible for people to live like
human beings about the so-called
disruptive child
but as the movement took off he needed
to step back and get out of the
limelight for a while so that people
wouldn't be distracted by the fact that
he was gay
that was really the piece that kept him
from
rising in the movement the way he could
have had he not been
if you were to look at bart and me on
the surface there were great differences
there was an age difference there was a
race difference
but we shared a deep bond and a deep
love for each other
in 1982 bayern adopted me so that we
would have some legal protections under
the law we were legal father and son
this was a time when gay couples hadn't
no protections no rights other people
were maybe a little shocked it didn't
really matter to us
died in august of 1987.
we decided to organize a small private
foundation in his memory the bard
wrestling fund
it was really designed to get barred
into the history books he didn't have
the visibility of a dr king or of a
malcolm x he would want to be remembered
for being a person that played a great
role in making social change to this
country
[Music]
you